foreign
[Music]
lately we got the impression that just
about every former Deadpool actor would
also be in Deadpool 3 plus of course
newcomer Hugh Jackman as Wolverine but
now it's clear at least one popular
character won't be back German American
actress zazi beats has now confirmed in
an interview with decider that she will
not return as domino in Deadpool 3. this
might come as a surprise to many as she
was an integral part of Deadpool 2. in
fact she doesn't have any info about the
third film but is definitely looking
forward to the outcome the project has
been the subject of some discussion
lately due to the writer strike not a
single line of the script may be changed
on set a big problem for Ryan Reynolds
and the team who usually improvise a lot
in order to find the best gags there is
also good news however unlike many
Disney Productions that have currently
been massively pushed back Deadpool 3 is
now scheduled to be released several
months earlier instead of November 2024
the new US release is now set for May 3
3rd 2024.
[Music]
foreign